this is how you make a thumbnail on
YouTube and this is why 99.9 of all the
discourse surrounding YouTube clickbait
is [__] I contract a very talented
artist to do some custom artwork for my
YouTube thumbnails and a different
additional artist to help composite
those Works into a final image for the
video and boy you would not believe the
amount of effort that goes into making
thumbnails I think a lot of people
underestimate the raw mad hours put into
these things for one of my most recent
videos that covered Full Metal Alchemist
we went through like a billion different
layout variations several different
compositions and entire redraws debates
on color schemes not to mention a whole
load of discussions on other elements
like titles and thumbnail text hours of
cumulative effort of a whole handful of
professionals all for a very tiny little
image that you see while you idle scroll
by on YouTube for maybe a quarter of a
second why would anyone initially
handicap themselves when no one else's
for the sake of fake Internet honor